vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique je pouvais
enlever les douleurs de règles ça
m'arrangerait beaucoup au quotidien donc
je pense que ça pareil je pense
bonjour je m'appelle Thierry Ardisson
j'ai décidé de poser aux gens les
questions que je posais au stade
vous auriez aimé ressembler à qui quand
vous étiez petit ça c'est une bonne
question à mon grand-père Kurt Cobain
Salvador Dali Cristiano Ronaldo à ma
mère plutôt mon père
US et j'aime beaucoup son style musical
et son flow surtout quand avez-vous
pleuré pour la dernière fois il y a 15
jours Fernand ma mère dernier film que
j'ai vu au décès de ma cousine alors là
pour mon ex il y a quelques semaines sur
la tombe de mon frère encore vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique plein de choses
tout toi oui tout moi
mon hésitation les cheveux qui se
cassent la gueule marocaine mon
caractère je mettrai 10 cm de plus je
ferais en sorte d'être plus diplomate
les rites qui commencent à apparaître
une meilleure vie sur 10
[Musique]
ventrale là qui s'installe à 40 balais
et ça a commencé à être un peu dur quel
péché vous tente le plus
la paresse
[Musique]
le vol le vol le vol ouais
que pourriez-vous dire depuis négatif
sur vous que je peux être con parfois
rien je suis parfait moi je me trouve
très bien
j'arrive pas à dire non quelle insulte
vous a fait le plus mal
dis-leur quand on m'a insulté d'orphelin
quand j'étais petit quand j'étais petite
qu'on me disait que j'étais bizarre
l'insulte raciste c'est une chose assez
triste mais on s'y habitue en fait va te
faire [ __ ] c'est d'être rabaisser un
genre de fille objet si ta vie était à
refaire tu changerais quoi j'aurais
acheté des Bitcoin il y a il y a 10 ans
mes relations amoureuse
quel est le surnom qu'on vous donne que
vous détestez le plus face d'ange doudou
le tous
souvent appelé swag c'est pas terrible
c'est pas tes pas du tout quel est votre
expression favorite
j'ai pas fait exprès à quelle heure
pour être belle laisse tomber genre au
jour d'aujourd'hui ou genre de trucs
ouais ça c'est insupportable qu'est-ce
que tu fais ce soir regarde à côté ce
qui se passe et en fait je m'en fous que
ça me concerne pas directement
travailler plus pour gagner plus
s'il y avait un génie là qui vous
propose d'exaucer un souhait et
choisiriez quoi enfin un petit peu
d'oseille la santé aussi bien entendu
mais un petit peu d'oseille quand même
c'est cool il faut savoir chanter c'est
bien ça
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu